do all Executives read save the cat I'm
going to say no based on what I've seen
uh they should um it's a good book I
look I it wasn't a text that I had in
grad school um I love the techniques of
screenwriting or Eugene Bale's you know
Bale's techniques of
screenwriting um the art of dramatic
writing by Leos egri um even Aristotle's
Poetics you know they're the books we
were given save the cat was a much more
modern take on you know a a modern
structure for a screenplay and I really
liked it I like that I like the way that
it's put together um I don't think
Blake's with this anymore but uh I did
it's a tough tone at times it can be a
little you know cowboy in the way that
it's presented but the way he's broken
up the segments of a screenplay and
identified the big beats in the
screenplay and also put in some um
understanding of the industry you know
it's not just a book about writing a
screenplay you a little bit of insight
into what it was like to try and sell a
screenplay and what that means and I
think and when I'm teaching
screenwriting because of the amount of
time I've spent in a studio you know in
developing and producing and and uh and
acquiring content uh I try to teach the
industry and not just the craft because
you know even in grad school at AFI it
was very much a an immersive here's the
craft this is the craft of film making
these are the collaborations that are
important these how they work here's how
to do a screenplay um all that kind of
stuff I didn't really get a lot of the
look at well okay that's great I have a
screenplay now what what do I do with it
you
know that needs to come before the idea
is put into you know you should know a
little bit about where your idea fits
and how the business works and so I try
to I I teach that when I'm teaching
screen screenwriting and I think that's
important it's not something that I even
when I was doing meteor in an undergrad
setting you know you learn all the
specifics about the craft but but
there's I mean in a grad course like I
did is there enough room to teach about
the business um no and so when my
schedule became a little more flexible I
went and got a temp job in a studio just
to see how things worked because a
friend of mine suggested doing that and
he worked at Sony um and that's how I
ended up getting kind of recruited out
of there as I started in when they used
to have a temp pool um is that I got to
know some people and how the business
worked while I was actually learning
continuing to learn about the craft in
my second year um but I think that's the
one thing that I wish had there had been
more
of that's fascinating so you didn't
really get it from an alumni connection
it was through these temp jobs yeah and
yeah I mean I could have could I have
done that could I have uh gone and
looked for you know we had a Mentor
system but gone and worked with them I
mean most people and I'm generalizing a
little bit but most people who become TV
writers for instance come up through the
writer assistant ranks you know and come
up through getting coffee all the way
through to the writers room and learning
about how they work and the mechanics of
that and the development of story that
way from a mentor system um when you're
in a film
School uh it's a little isolated and
you're in a bubble so you're learning
The Craft you're not exposed as much to
the business unless you become proactive
yourself and I knew that I had to cuz I
didn't know anyone you know I I'm from
the theater so I'm trying to convert
that knowledge into an understanding of
writing for film and TV and so I wanted
to learn about how the business worked
and turns out I turned that into a
career has seeve the cat ruined in a
sense the movie
industry that's a big one I'm going to
have to say no no it hasn't um um I
think it's given a unique perspective on
structure um on a simplistic level to
people
who might not be screenwriters you know
Studio executive Network Executives um
if you're willing to have a look at how
something works and and how it's
generated and how it aists a response
from an audience and a marketing
perspective I've only read the first one
I think there's another couple of save
the cats that have come out I've never
read those but I liked this one and you
know I I have you know taken from it
because there are there are kind of
Ideal you know beats in it that do work
and you can lay those templates over
some of the greater films you know and I
I try to do that in my classes as well
not from save the cat but you know from
those models um but when you look at uh
Leos EG's kind of uh his take on
character and how where he believed
character comes from um Eugene Vil's
book the techniques of screenwriting um
they do cover the same ground um but say
the cat is a little more modern in its
approach I think um and I I liked the
book you know I think it has a lot to
say about structure um can you work
outside of structure sure of course you
can I don't know how you do that though
until you know structure first so the
idea of working gain structure um even
you know movies like momento which have
a very strange kind of structure to them
they still work inside a 3A structure
that you can lay over it that has big
beats that elicit a response in that
moment and I think that's the value of
the biggest value of save the C for me
is really honing and defining what each
of those segments is between those big
beats you know that setup you know the
opening and closing image of a film how
important are they you know for instance
if you lay that over the apartment Billy
Wilder which is one of my favorite
movies of all time um you'll see in the
opening shot it's an out it's a it's a
picture of the outside of the apartment
building it's very cold it's very kind
of clinical you know it's very rigid but
in the closing in the closing shot of
the apartment it's it's inside the
apartment with with Jack Lemon and
Shirley mlan and they've found each
other you know they're together and
there's a warmth to it there's a
contrast in those book ends um and I
think it was reading save the cat and
having a look at that structure and the
importance of those moments and how they
show a character arc when you when you
book in them like that um does that
happen in every movie no not necessarily
but a lot of the a lot of them a lot of
the good ones um and the importance of
the setup section the debate section in
between the inciting incident and the
end of Act One what's going on there
what's supposed to to happen there you
know um the fun and game section where
most act big action pieces happen in
between the midpoint and the First Act
and then his bad guys closing in you
know towards the end of the second act I
found all all of that I knew the
information but the way that he put it
was very succinct and very accessible I
think why do you think the book is so
polarizing we see it in our comments we
hear it from people in person they
either love it or intensely like it yeah
I think that's just opinion um you would
have to go to each one of them and say
why why why are you commenting on this
book um I think that you know we want
what we do sometimes to be complex you
know there is we want it to be
inaccessible I don't want everyone to
know how to do this um but the fact is
that if you work hard enough and you you
learn you can do it on a certain level
um you know uh I think that is
polarizing because for me if I was to
offer that opinion which is all it would
be cuz I don't know what everyone thinks
but it does have a certain tone to it
that that could read is arrogant you
know um and you'll hear that every now
and then but it's only because Blake
Snider and his partner really did go
through the mud of how do I get a film
made you know how do I sell a screenplay
what does it take you know um and I
think I think it's that you know is is
is there is a there is a tone to it and
I picked up on it but again I can only
offer my opinion on that I don't know
why it's polarizing all I know is I read
it a number of times and I got little
things out of it that I incorporated
into my own process you know because I
found it useful based on my own
knowledge I think anyone who want you
know the book Banning in this country
needs to
stop so should we take all save the cats
out and burn them cuz you don't like
them I don't think so if you don't like
it bully for you read something else um
but I think it does have something to
offer if you really look into it because
Blake had a really good career in the
industry and you can't deny that um but
at the same time there is a a confidence
in the tone with which he puts it
forward and I think that can that can
kind of put up a wall for people um it
it's it's not overly friendly to our
current pronoun environment for instance
and I think a lot of books are like that
um people are a lot more aware of that
now um as they should be uh but I think
that you know that and even if you go
back to some of the more classic books
that Robert mck and that you you'll find
the pronouns are a
wall um and I think maybe it's that
too